Hey everyone, Ryan here, and welcome back to our Peridontic series.
So here's a reminder of all the categories that the board exam tests in Peridontics.
So far we've covered diagnosis of Peridontal disease, including different classifications
for things like forcation involvement and gingeral recession.
We also talked extensively about etiology like plaque and other local factors.
This video will cover the high yield information for the Peridontal disease process, focusing
on what you need to know for the board exam.
And in later videos we'll talk about treatment planning, prognosis, and the heavily requested
Peridontal treatment, both surgical and non-surgical, then we'll finish up by talking about prevention
and maintenance.
So like I mentioned in the very first video, Peridontal disease is an interplay between
bacteria and the host.
Plaque is the initiating factor, and the host responds often damaging its own tissue in
order to protect itself.
So it's important to talk about the immune cells that play a part in this response.
So the first cell we'll talk about is the neutrophil, and neutrophils are the first
line of defense, and they're considered the most important cells involved in controlling
this bacterial challenge and destroying peridontal tissue via release of destructive molecules.
So all of those bacteria that we talked about in the third video, like P. gingivalis and
all of these other pathogenic bacteria, are the attackers, neutrophils are the primary
defenders.
So neutrophils are going to migrate from blood vessels that are underneath the gingiva into
the peridontal pocket by directed locomotion known as chemotaxis, where they form a barrier
to protect the body from these peridontal pathogenic bacteria.
They internalize the bacteria via phagocytosis, so they eat them and then kill them using
this biologic bleach.
It's a really nasty chemical of myeloparoxide and oxygen radicals.
So this stuff is nasty for the bacteria and they can't really survive with this mix of
chemicals.
MMP8, also known as neutrophil collagenase, is the most important proteinase involved
in destruction of peridontal tissues, and it's inhibited by this antibiotic tetracycline.
So MMPs are really important destructive enzymes to know, and they'll come up again later in
the video, and basically what this slide is saying is that neutrophils are the first responders,
they sniff out the invading bacteria, follow where they are by chemotaxis, eat them by
phagocytosis, and then release strong destructive enzymes that not only kill the bacteria inside
of them, but they also destroy peridontal tissue around them.
So neutrophils, like any cell in the body, can perform not well, and there can be abnormalities
associated with them.
So defective neutrophil chemotaxis, for example, can lead to aggressive peridontitis.
So we talked about certain bacteria that can cause aggressive peridontitis, that would
be the really long name, acrogatibacter, actinomycetimcomatans, we remember that because the AA bacteria
causes the A form of peridontitis, but also a problem with the own body response can cause
this form of peridontitis as well, so that's important to know.
The problem with neutrophils and when they don't work properly is it's a lose-lose situation.
If you have too much neutrophil activity, you can cause too much tissue destruction, and
if you have too little, it can lead to an unchecked bacteria challenge, which also leads
to tissue destruction.
So it has to be just right in order to prevent this unnecessary tissue damage, but of course,
the best possible scenario is to not have these invading pathogenic bacteria.
And other neutrophil abnormalities include these, I wouldn't need to know those for
the board exam, so don't worry so much about those.
So the next immune cell we'll talk about is the macrophage, and these are antigen-presenting
cells, including monocytes and dendritic cells, and they regulate the immune response by releasing
cytokines like IL-8.
Mass cells are also involved.
They cause vascular permeability and dilation of blood vessels, and they're really well-known
to produce IgE.
This is immunoglobulin E, and they're antibodies that are famously produced by mass cells.
This is a pretty common board question, part one and part two boards could ask this sort
of question.
Remembering IgE is always associated with the mass cell.
And lymphocytes is another category of immune cells to know for the peridontal response.
So B cells become plasma cells and make antibodies.
The T helper cells, also known as CD4 cells, that's because the CD4 is a glycoprotein found
on the surface of these cells, and they help with communication between all the different
immune cells.
The T set of toxic cells, also called CD8 cells, because CD8 is a glycoprotein found
on the surface of these cells, they directly kill intracellular antigens.
And then we have NK cells, which stands for natural killer cells.
There are specific type of T cell that can recognize and kill tumor and virally infected
cells.
So all of these cells can, of course, like the macrophages and the mass cells and the
neutrophils.
There's a lot of interplay in the immune system, and so each of these has a very specific role
to play when responding to any sort of infection.
So the pro-inflammatory mediators are listed here, these are those chemicals that favor
the destructive nature of peridontal disease, where the body destroys itself in order to
protect itself from the peridontal pathogens.
That's that sort of innate irony of peridontal disease, or the oxymoron of peridontal disease.
So for these, maybe don't remember all the specific numbers, if you have room for this
kind of information, that's great.
If not, I would walk away knowing MMPs is the most important thing to take away from
this video.
MMP stands for matrix metalloproteinase and proteinase, anything that's an ACE is an enzyme,
and so it eats proteins, that's what proteinase means, and that's exactly what it does.
It destroys the most common protein in the human body, which is collagen.
So MMPs destroying collagen, and collagen's certainly present in the ginger bus, so it's
going to be causing a lot of localized tissue damage, and is a primary mediator in the peridontal
tissue destruction process.
So definitely no MMPs, and those are released again by the neutrophils.
And just like we have pro-inflammatory mediators, we also have anti-inflammatory mediators, and
those are some of the ones listed below.
And so these oppose that tissue destruction, so it's a constant balance between pro and
anti-inflammatory mediators, both of which are sort of sitting on opposite ends of a
seesaw.
So some specifics, the pathogenesis of gingivitis, there are four different stages outlined here.
The initial lesion occurs within two to four days, and it starts with neutrophil infiltration.
Again, that's that first line of defense by the human body.
Stage two is considered an early lesion, that's from four to seven days, and the T lymphocytes
are the next cell to sort of step up to the plate and attack.
When you see the early lesion, you see increased collagen loss and bleeding on probing.
So more classic signs of gingival inflammation.
Stage three is considered an established lesion.
This is 14 to 21 days, and then the B cells step up to the plate.
They infiltrate, including mature, they also grow into mature plasma cells, so they're
releasing antibodies, and causing more collagen loss, clinical changes in color, contour,
and consistency.
Again, those are our three C's associated with gingivitis, and now we're really getting
into an established gingivitis situation.
And stage four, an advanced lesion, this is where we get transitioned to irreversible
damage.
Again, all this, these first three stages are the reversible stages of gingivitis.
Once we get bone loss at stage four, that irreversible damage, now we've transitioned
to periodontitis, where we have irreversible tissue damage.
So as mentioned before, environmental and systemic factors like smoking and diabetes
might influence the progression of periodontal disease, but these things don't cause disease.
Again, without plaque, you're not going to get this immune response, you're not going
to get periodontal disease.
So thanks again for watching everyone.
I hope you found this video helpful in your studies, and we'll see you all in the next
video.